salut comme tous les jours je vous donne
une énigme pendant ses 32 jours d'été et
avant de vous donner l'énigme du jour je
vous donne la solution de l'énigme
d'hier
si vous n'avez pas vu les digues d'hier
il faut foncer la regarder avant de
connaître la réponse sinon ça va pas
d'intérêt et la réponse à l'énigme
d'hier et chacun a pris le cheval de
l'autre et comme leur père avait dit et
celui d'entre vous dont le cheval
arrivera en dernier héritera de ma
fortune
ils ont tout intérêt à aller plus vite
que l'autre puisque l'autre à son propre
cheval vous comprenez l'idée chacun des
deux frères a pris le cheval de l'autre
à l'écurie et c'est pour ça qu'ils font
ce le plus vite possible
il fallait juste prendre en compte ce
changement de cheval bravo à tous ceux
qui ont réussi et ceux qui n'ont pas
forcément réussi vous allez peut-être
être plus à l'aise avec l'énigme
d'aujourd'hui 7/8 henning c'est une
possibilité mathématique c'est à dire
que deux égal 1 on va apprendre de
lettres a et b à égal un ep égal 1 voilà
comment je vais écrire tout une formule
à égal un ep égal 1 ça veut dire que à
égal b jusqu'ici tout va bien
en maths on sait que si je mets le même
facteur à gauche et à droite ça ne
change rien à l'équation donc je vais
multiplier les deux côtés par de la même
manière si je retiens exactement la même
somme des deux côtés ça ne change rien
donc je vais retirer b x v de chaque
côté maintenant à gauche je vais
rajouter 0 mais pas en écrivant 0 en le
symbolisant par une petite équation a
soit b mois à x b si je changeais a et b
par n'importe quelle valeur ça ferait
bien 0 quand même au final et à droite
veut dire exactement la même chose sauf
que pour l'écrire d'une manière plus
simplifié je vais mettre ben est un
facteur
maintenant je fais exactement paris pour
la gauche je vais mettre une mise en
facteur c'est à dire je ne change rien à
l'équation je ne rajoute rien je
n'enlève rien je mets juste une mise en
facteur pour simplifier l'écriture je
vous le fais en deux temps histoire de
pas vous perdre là maintenant je refais
une mise en facteur par a plus b
donc j'ai rien rajouter j'ai rien
enlever c'est toujours la même chose
maintenant on va simplifier c'est à dire
que effectivement en maths on met le
même facteur de chaque côté ça ne change
rien si on leur tire exactement le même
facteur de chaque côté ça ne change rien
non plus donc je supprime le facteur x à
moimbé des deux côtés il nous reste donc
a + b et galp et et commencer que à égal
un épais et gagnent 1 ça fait bien de
égal 1 et là on fait mais non c'est un
scandale c'est impossible je suis tout à
fait d'accord avec vous cependant la
démonstration mathématique est bonne
alors pourquoi à quel endroit il ya une
arnaque
je vous donne un petit indice ne
cherchait pas dans les mises en facteur
je vous ai pas embrouiller elles sont
correctes tout est correct
pourtant il ya une arnaque
laquelle vous inquiétez pas je vous
donne la réponse de moi je sais que
celle ci est beaucoup plus compliqué si
vous avez la réponse ne la mettez pas
dans les commentaires vous pouvez en
parler sans dévoiler la réponse pour
laisser tout le monde cherchait par
contre si vous avez trouvez vous mettez
un pouce en l'air comme ça on sait quel
est le nombre de personnes qui a trouvé
ou et telle arnaque pour terminer cette
vidéo vous pouvez compléter les phrases
que jeudi en même temps que moi ça me
fait plaisir de me dire que vous
connaissez la suite profitez bien du
soleil passer un bel été n'oubliez pas
de vous abonner avant de partir et
rendez vous demain à 17 heures ciao